gerade hat uns die nachricht erreicht
dass die regierung jetzt noch viel
strengere maßnahmen im kampf gegen
korona planen und darüber möchten wir
jetzt direkt sprechen mit bild vize paul
ronzheimer bei uns im studio
paul was genau ist jetzt der plan vor
allem von bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
ja es gibt zwei diskussionen nele zum
einen wird darüber gesprochen was nach
weihnachten passieren könnte
und da drängt das kanzleramt auf einen
härteren auf einen knallhart locker und
so muss man es sagen dass möglicherweise
direkt nach weihnachten bis zum dritten
januar oder 10
januar auch dass auch diese zahl wird
genannt alles geschlossen werden soll
bis auf supermärkte das ist das was im
kanzleramt diskutiert wird jetzt muss
man sagen dass es da gegenwehr der
bundesländer gibt insbesondere berlin
hamburg mecklenburg vorpommern schleswig
holstein also das alte spielt das
kanzleramt möchte härter durchgreifen
und die länder sind dagegen die
entscheidende frage wird jetzt sein
findet in dieser woche womöglich noch
eine ministerpräsidentenkonferenz stadt
auch das ist das was die kanzlerin
möchte
einige länder sind dagegen also man
streitet sich mal wieder gleichzeitig
hat die kanzlerin heute in der fraktion
im bundestag in der cdu fraktion sehr
klar gesagt man muss noch etwas machen
auch vor weihnachten und da kommt die
zweite debatte ins spiel denn da geht es
um die hotspots was ist bei den werten
von über 200 instituts wert was kann man
da machen verschärfte maßnahmen auch das
wird diskutiert also wir halten fest was
wir gestern ja auch schon von
kanzleramtsminister helge braun hier im
studio gehört haben dass man mehr will
die frage ist kann sich die ganze und am
ende durchsetzen
paul jobs wirklich dass so viel mehr das
große ganze dass es erst nach
weihnachten kommt und warum warten wir
damit so lange ich glaube dass
möglicherweise die hotspot frage vorher
geklärt wird also was passiert wirklich
bei einem besonders landkreis wo es ein
ganz ganz hohen wert gibt aber die
andere frage ist was tut man jetzt vor
weihnachten und diesen knall hat
lockdown den kann man ja wenn man ihn
denn will sowie teile im kanzleramt eben
sagen nicht wirklich vor weihnachten
umsetzen wie soll das gehen ja also die
menschen die jetzt noch
schenkel kaufen wollen zum beispiel ja
kann man denen dann sagen wir machen
jetzt alles dicht und bleiben wirklich
nur noch supermärkte offen
also ich glaube das möchte man
verhindern und möchte so zu sagen dann
in wahrheit vom 24 dezember bis zum
dritten jahr nur eine phase schaffen wo
dann wirklich die menschen sich kaum
noch versammeln wo sie auch dann in
geschäften nicht aneinander gereiht
stehen und nur noch die supermärkte
offen werden und wenn man sich die werte
an schaut also wenn man sich die reinen
infektionszahlen anschaut dann muss man
sagen dass sie ja sich wieder leicht
verschärft haben weshalb die kanzlerin
sich da auf der richtigen seite wähnt
dass sie sagt sie will noch härtere
maßnahmen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei der schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren